Are you in the Smoky Mountains?
I am in the Rocky Mountains, yeah.
I've been here for a while already,
so yeah, I can't complain.
It's been beautiful.
Wow. I know you're like kicking it in your Eames chair.
Just like staring out a window with a fire.
Yes, yes, that's my reading chair, so-
and also, you were my first childhood crush.
Oh well
So yeah,
Thank you.
I mean, I just wanted to get that out of the way
so we can continue.
Yeah, I mean ET was the first movie that I ever saw
in a theater
Oh it was Gertie.
That was, okay.
I was picturing like Poison Ivy, but yeah, good.
Gertie.
(audience laughing)
Yeah. I mean, I was
I think that we're pretty much contemporary.
We're almost the same age and
Yes, and yesterday was your birthday.
Happy birthday.
It was my birthday, that's right, thank you.
You know, it's been great.
I love snowboarding.
So, I spent my birthday on the slopes
and with some friends, so
yeah, I can't complain.
I'm very lucky.
You're actually, like you just got into snowboarding,
right?
Is this a new hobby?
Is this like, are you-
I mean,
I did the reboot of "Point Break" a few years ago.
You know, the movie from the 90s.
Oh, of course I know
Yeah, exactly.
And, Keanu Reeves did, so I was lucky enough to play Bodhi,
to play Patrick Swayze's character.
But the irony was that
the extreme sports were so extreme
that we were not allowed
to do anything.
Right.
So we went to the most beautiful places for snowboard,
for proximity flight, for surf,
and we were not allowed to do anything
because of course, I mean,
had I broken an ankle, then
the movie would have stopped.
So, it stayed with me that eventually
I will
make it up to myself
to learn to commit.
And now, it's really working.
So, I got my new board and I'm very excited.
So, I've been hitting the slopes
anytime I have a chance.
It's my new passion
I love that.
And, I was really excited to talk to you and hear your story
and celebrate this movie, "Yes Day",
that is streaming now on Netflix,
which has so much more
to me
of a thematic nature
that I think we could adopt
in all of our lives and see how it goes
and trust in the process.
Have a "Yes Day".
Yeah
Totally, and restore the balance, you know
or the imbalance that is completely natural
to any
personal dynamic
may that be with your children or with your partner.
Because that is something that for us
was also very important to tackle in the film,
that normally when you,
in a lot of movies are made for the entire family,
you see that the entire focus is on the relationship
between the parents or the children.
But for Jennifer Garner,
the beautiful, talented, Jennifer Garner,
who invited me to be a part of this
amazing film,
for us it was very important to also explore the dynamic
within the couple and also the imbalances within the couple.
The imbalances that come from the awesome responsibility
that it is to raise children.
And for me, it was very important to see
that my character learns how to be accountable,
and how to be responsible,
and how to be
involved.
I think that it's very important to
for everybody to get involved
and for everybody to learn how to be flexible and say yes
when he needs,
when it's needed to be,
and also, you know
be able to say also a loving no, you know?
A no that is also going to provide a structure
and guidance to the children.
This is what I'm talking about, Edgar.
People are afraid as parents to say, no.
They think their kids will not love them.
And the truth is,
It's not
a popularity contest.
No its actually creating safety.
It's like
Exactly.
kids thrive with bumper rails.
I've got everything you're saying is so on point.
It really is.
Thank you.
You're so incredibly insightful .
This is a very personal movie for me.
I love this movie and I love the concept of a Yes Day.
And I think that, I really hope that it becomes a movement
and that we're flexible and kind enough to be gentle
to ourselves and to the people that we love.
And we keep saying yes
after such a big no
that this year has been.
That is my biggest wish today.
Well, happy post birthday.
I hope all of your wishes come true.
And, "Yes Day" is streaming now on Netflix.
There's so much beauty in everything of this conversation.
Thank you, Edgar.
Thank you Drew, its been amazing to talk to you
And again, you were the first actress I've ever saw
in a theater, you know,
and it's been very special to talk to you.
I was very, very excited about this conversation.
Thank you so much.
Thank you sou much.
(upbeat music)